[Musik]
mittlerweile knapp 17.000 Jahren nicht
mehr geblockt habe dachte ich mir
war eigentlich die beste 17.000 Jahre
meines Lebens burger King hat ein Bikini
bottom-menü rausgebracht und da ist mein
allergrößter Kindheitstraum war selbst
mal den Krabbenburger probieren zu
dürfen habe ich mir gedacht
es könnte auch sein dass ich nach dem
heutigen Video meine komplette Kindheit
zerstört habe gedacht dass wir heute mal
zusammen zu Burger King gehen und
gemeinsam den krabbenburg
er und da meine Kamera in der Reparatur
ist für mich heute mit dem Handy wow
ihr wollt ich eigentlich gerade eine
coole timelapse aufnehmen wie ich mir
mein Frühstück zubereitet habe aber dann
können wir bitte auch mal ganz kurz
festhalten was ich für ein
geisteskrankes Multitasking Genie bin
guck mal hier ich mache während ich die
Eier schlagen Guacamole auf meinem Brot
drauf und
schicke die Zwiebeln in der Pfanne
unfassbar mittlerweile schon 14 Uhr und
ich habe einfach sein Frühstück
vergessen
hässlichster Ort in ganz Köln
Barbarossaplatz ich weiß immer noch
nicht wie die hier die Verkehrsführung
hingekriegt haben so oder so werde ich
auf jeden Fall gerade zum Friseur
[Musik]
willst du einen grüßen hi Grüße kommen
seit 30
Digger ich glaube ich bin tatsächlich so
verfickten Nagel gefahren und muss mir
dann neuen Fahrradreifen kaufen den ich
auch noch selbst aufpumpen musste super
geiler Vlog ist ja klasse na ja
wenigstens würde ich beim Training dann
freundlich empfangen
Training ist übrigens nicht so der
Proteinshake sondern
Ernährung und deswegen fahren wir jetzt
zu Burger King und jetzt den neuen
Krabbenburger
ich war so nicht leidet soll
Drachen lernen Babbel
okay ich bin gespannt das hier ist der
Bikini bottom-burger mit SpongeBob
übrigens diese Kerze hat mit Jeremy
fragments geschenkt und wenn man die
anzündet hört sich es einfach an als
würde neben einem Pappkarton abbrennen
Werft so hart allerdings würde ich sagen
dass damit unser schönes Ambiente jetzt
angerichtet ist und das hier der
Krabbenburger sein soll
Jeremy
gebrannt sein
ich habe gerade mal gegoogelt und diese
gelbe Soße die hier auf dem
Krabbenburger drauf ist ist anscheinend
eine ananasoße wegen Bikini Bottom und
im Haus wo Spongebob drin wohnt eine
Ananas
aber irgendwann bei dem Unterwasser
nicht gut
also klar draußen
ich glaube das wird gepflückt als ich
noch nicht auf der Welt war oder so bin
ich aber ganz ehrlich dieses Gemüse
Patty oder was auch immer da drin ist
weil das Ding ist die vegetarisch oder
egal keine Ahnung
irgendwie so halb auseinander
die Ananas
rausgeflogen keine
ich würde mir den auf keinen Fall normal
bestellen
aber es ist okay
es sind gerade 24 Stunden später
und ich schneide gerade den Block und
ist gerade aufgefallen dass ich einfach
nach dem Burger essen nicht mehr weiter
gefilmt
es the biggest piece the dark Shirt
ehrlich gesagt könnte jetzt abschalten
[Musik]
und dann
verstehe was essen geschlafen
[Musik]
ich bin irgendwie ein bisschen am
struggle immer mit meinem Knipser aber
ich habe den schon
ich habe den halt schon voll lange
deswegen
[Musik]
ihr schaltet jetzt besser